I was diagnosed with stage 3 colon
cancer at in 2003 I was 26 years old
there aren't a whole lot of 26 year olds
that get colon cancer it causes
secondary cancers right
there's no doctor that will deny or
argue with the fact that chemotherapy is
also carcinogenic right that's why when
they administer it they have to wear two
sets of gloves and if it spills on the
floor there's this very specific
procedure to clean it up it's they
cannot get it on their skin about
homemade salad dressing extra-virgin
olive oil
organics of course better but this is
not organic and I put this on pretty
liberally usually going a couple circles
go around like this and then Bragg's
organic apple cider vinegar so I'll be
the main reason I didn't do it is it
destroys your immune system when it's
killing rapidly reproducing cells one of
the one of the main parts of your
Anatomy that it destroys are your white
blood cells this coconut open and you'll
see there's the meat inside is the
coconut juice so what I want to do is
put that juice in my blender I bet
everyone in this room has probably heard
this story from somebody with cancer
they got cancer they went through
surgery they had chemotherapy a few
months ago by big announcement there's
no evidence of cancer it's gone
everybody's so excited right and then a
few months later to a year later its
back but this time it's all over their
body it's just like taken over and
that's why it's cuz their immune system
is gone and it causes secondary cancer
so you've got this double whammy effect
with chemo what are you gonna do with it
if somebody's been trying to deliver
something to you like we've been trying
to deliver the truth
greenies apiece welcome to the DS show
subscribe if you haven't already my next
guest was diagnosed with cancer at a
young age he's here on the Dean show to
give those some hope some good feeling
after a long feeling of probably
helplessness maybe you've been diagnosed
with cancer you're one of the 50%
you fought less one and two expected to
have cancer you've been diagnosed with
it or you want to prevent it now here's
some things that you can do that go
beyond the conventional methods that I
think and I know for sure if you have an
open mart mind you're sincere and you
want to know you'll truly benefit from
this individuals unique story and many
people are going towards this way of
connecting and putting into the body the
things that the created at the crater
that the Almighty has given us it's our
god-given right so make sure you make
some time watch this episode with this
exciting show with my next guest Chris
who beak cancer we right back welcome
back to the D show I have a special
treat we have Chris Chris be cancer with
us here on the D show how are you my
friend I'm doing well how are you good
thank God good good thank you for being
with us paint us a picture Chris I want
to know you know have it hit home
because we know 50% is that correct 50%
of people it's estimated living today
will have cancer one in three males will
die from it is this correct that's all
right
you know one in every two men will be
diagnosed and I'm not sure if the one in
every three will die from it is correct
but we know that one or two men and a
little bit less than one out of every
three women are predicted to be
diagnosed with cancer in their lifetime
so it's yeah pretty significant problem
in the Western world now look at you
having a young man you know full of life
I mean you think someone gets cancer
when they're like in their 60 70s but
how old were you when you were diagnosed
with cancer I was writing this at 26 and
young adult cancer is on the rise and so
is a you know childhood cancer the rates
of childhood can
serve exploded rates of young adult
cancer have risen sharply in the last
few decades and this is because our diet
and lifestyle so toxic we live in a
toxic world we're surrounded by
environmental pollution and we're eating
a diet that is loaded with artificial
flavors colors fats right and
preservatives all kinds of stuff that
your body was never meant to ingest now
paint that picture that I was asking you
earlier that now I mean you're going
about your life and what what is it you
get a pain people can't fathom like how
does that feel what what's the emotion
what what's the signals that you're
getting and then finally you're
diagnosed paint that scenario that
picture for us yeah well you know it's
everyone it's different for everybody
but for me I was having abdominal pain
and I thought I had an ulcer and I put
it off for months and then eventually
went to the doctor because the pain
gradually got worse and worse over time
and they thought I had an ulcer too and
and gave me some medication didn't help
and eventually I had a colonoscopy
because the gastroenterologist was like
well we don't really know what else to
do so why don't we have a look around in
there and see what we see and he saw a
golf-ball-sized tumor in my large
intestine that's and so they took a
biopsy and send it to the lab and called
me I guess the next day or the next
usually the next day or the two days
later instead the tests came back and
you have colon cancer I mean okay so
you're a young man you know late 20s
early 20s and you get 26 you get this
news what were you doing before then
what was your lifestyle like I mean with
stars food and just you know being
active and what was your lifestyle like
before you know I was a real estate
entrepreneur so it's really busy a lot
of stress I was ripped renting houses
flipping houses trying to build a
business and just running around eating
a standard American diet tons of fast
food processed food junk food lots of
meat and dairy sugar salt oil you know
all this processed Western diet garbage
really and it's the same diet that most
Americans eat is what I was eating it
just caught up to me a lot sooner than
most Americans right but like I said a
minute ago young adult cancer is on the
rise I was in the fast
a generation like I grew up on fast food
and my parents did not write fast food
really took off in the 80s and then of
course the nineties and you know today
it's bigger than ever and so that's why
we're seeing such an increase in cancer
rates and young people now you the
cancer specialists are the oncologists
right so did you go see an oncologist
then he was talking about doing some
chemo radiation was that an option on
the table that you were exploring so the
first thing they did was they rush me
into surgery because they said look you
got this tumor we got to get it out of
you before it spreads and kills you
which is what they tell every cancer
patient there's always this sort of rush
of fear and panic right that you we've
got to get you into treatment right away
there's no time to waste
you know it doesn't matter that it's
been growing for ten years you know now
it's about to kill you overnight that's
that's always the way they treat cancer
patients so I was rushed into surgery I
had surgery a week later after I was
diagnosed it was December 30th 2003 not
to give away the ending of the story
right and and then they they found out
it was stage 3c so it was worse than
they thought they told me I needed nine
to twelve months of chemotherapy and a
couple things happened in the hospital
that got me thinking differently about
the medical industry and the first thing
that happened was the the first meal
that they served me after cutting out a
third third of my large intestine was a
sloppy joe right no huapi job and then a
sloppy joe has yeah so yeah I mean you
know it's like mystery me slopped on a
burger bun it's like the worst cafeteria
food you can think of right it's like
what they feed you no kids at summer
camp a cafeteria lunch food right
military rations Wow and it was just
shocked that they were feeding this to
me after cutting out part of my guts
right and then the few days later the
surgeon comes in
operated on me and I asked him are there
any foods I need to be eating or
avoiding because you know instinctively
I thought yeah maybe maybe there's some
food I should eat you know my instincts
were telling me that my diet mattered
right so I asked the surgeon and he said
no I just don't lift anything heavier
than a beer Wow
that was it that was the advice that was
it that was it is it was it and so you
know I left the hospital went home and I
was recovering from surgery and you know
it was rough I mean they could they cut
me open and like you know all my my
abdominal muscles were trying to grow
back together and my wife and I were
well you know I would I'm getting head
of myself but I was having this
increasing uncertainty about
chemotherapy I just couldn't imagine
myself going through that it's I didn't
want to do it like my instincts were
telling me no like don't do that and but
I didn't know what else to do and so I
feel not afraid about it we're
Christians or believers and so like you
know I'm just like god help like I don't
know what to do if there's another way
besides chemotherapy just please show me
I showed me the way and two days later a
book shows up on my doorstep that was
mailed to me from a man in Alaska I live
in Tennessee and this book was called
God's way to ultimate health a common
sense guide for eliminating sickness
through nutrition some way less
interesting you know right I asked for
that I asked for some help and this book
shows up so I start to read it and I
learned right away that the author of
the book had watched his mother suffer
and die from cancer treatment not from
cancer he had watched many people he
knew suffer and die from cancer and
cancer treatment and he was a pastor of
a church and then he got diagnosed with
colon cancer just like me and but he
made a very different decision he
refused chemotherapy surgery radiation
and he had a body that said you need to
go back to eating like they did in the
Garden of Eden
in Genesis you need to eat a diet of
just raw fruits and vegetables and also
you should drink a lot of carrot juice
and this isn't a book this is every day
yeah yeah this is this man's story yeah
and year later his tumor was gone so
he's thought about going back to eat
real food the way that God intended for
us to eat real food right that's right
real food from the earth whole food
right organic and his body healed I
can't you know tumor went away in a year
what's gone you know and I was just like
this is it like I prayed I got this like
this book and I'm this is what I'm gonna
do this is exactly what I'm gonna do and
I'm overnight I converted to a raw vegan
diet I went out bought a juicer bought
giant 25 pound bags of organic juicing
carrots and I went from eating 1 to 2
servings of fruits and vegetables every
day to eating between 15 and 20 servings
of fruits and vegetables every single
day and I'm going to tell you that makes
a huge impact in your health when you do
that and so I started feeling really
good and if you don't felt kind of bad
at first because you know a lot of us
have junk food withdrawals meat and
dairy withdrawal protein withdrawal like
we just start to feel bad if we make a
radical change like that it's very
normal for your body to not know what to
do and it takes a little time for the
body to adapt and but so after the sort
of break-in period of 3 or 4 days of
feeling kind of lousy I felt amazing
and from there you know I was really
excited about just going down this path
but I was surrounded by people my wife
who loves me and a lot of family members
who thought I was completely nuts they
thought I was making a huge mistake and
they were trying to talk me out of it
and there was so much pressure to talk
you out of what going to do the chemo
talked me out of what I was doing
yeah because I didn't I told them I
don't really want to do chemo yeah and
there was so much pressure that I
reluctantly agreed to go see the
oncologist because you know I mean if
when everyone around you is telling you
please please go talk to the doctor
please listen to us but you know like
okay
okay right so you know we go to see the
oncologist he told me I had a 60% chance
of living five years with treatment like
well that's not encouraging I asked him
about the raw food diet he said you
can't do that it'll fight the chemo
I asked him if there were any
alternative therapies available and he
said no there are none
if you don't do chemotherapy you're
insane and I left that appointment so so
afraid and you know just completely in
in this totally stressed anxious fearful
state and I went made an appointment to
get a port put in in a few weeks to
start chemo you know I went into the
clinic confident in what I was doing
feeling good and I left terrified
because that's the way cancer clinics
operate they're like a fear factory and
all they're doing is you know promoting
all this fear to manipulate patients to
say yes to treatment before they even
have a chance to think about their life
and why they're sick well you already
you said you started to feel better
before you went in your confidence was
drawn in the raw fear not for a week and
just from a week you started to feel
tremendous yeah difference I was feeling
really good and really confident and and
it was just all that confidence was
shattered in one appointment with this
doctor can we say that the the doctors
oncologists they're doing what they're
trained to do that do they study
nutrition do they study this is a whole
new world this is a whole new science of
food and nutrition so do they get any
training there about this yeah but do
you think it's not a new science for
that I mean for that that's the thing
it's not personal science is not new but
but you know they don't get training
okay they're not trained on nutrition so
they can't advise you not trained on how
to use nutrition to help patients heal
their chronic diseases what they're
trained to do is prescribe a drug to
help with the symptoms of a chronic
disease actually they're trained to
perform surgical procedures to remove
body parts that are affected by a
chronic disease that was caused in most
cases by your bad diet and they're
trained to give you chemotherapy to kill
cancer cells which doesn't solve the
underlying problem
your body the reason that you have
cancer is not the tumor right the tumor
is the symptom of the disease it is not
the disease itself the disease is head
to toe you're sick you've got a sick
body you have a metabolic disease you're
overloaded you're toxic
you are probably stressed to the max and
you're not taking care of yourself and
you're in an environment you may be
working around toxic chemicals or had
some toxic chemical exposure but but for
most cancer patients there is a
convergence of multiple health
destroying factors in their life that
are all present right that are
persisting in their life for many months
or years and that leads them into cancer
right it it breaks them down over time
that become vulnerable and weak and
their body becomes a place where cancer
can thrive because what we know is that
everyone has cancer cells there are
thousands of cancer cells potentially
that form in your body every day but
your immune system is designed to
identify and eliminate those rogue cells
but it's only when you're overloaded and
toxic and your immune system is
suppressed or overloaded or both right
that it can't keep up keep up with the
demand well and that's when cancer
that's when two lumps bumps lesions
tumors form and are allowed to sort of
grow unchecked in the body it's like
when did you think that you had no
purpose
are you worthless the value comes from
purpose your purpose in life is to
worship the Creator no worship your
desires himself not worship social
pressure the celebrity culture but
worship the thing that's much higher and
transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure many people people have you
have you found that they find this very
difficult or they're not conscious that
there's such a strong food sickness
relationship yeah most people don't have
any connection to that their diet is
making them sick they've never been told
that their doctors are certainly aren't
talking to them what we know is that
when you look around the world at pop
population studies and disease rates
around the world they're very different
than the US when you look at rural
countries developing countries
third-world countries have much lower
rates of most of the cancers we have
breast cancer colon cancer lung cancer
prostate cancer a lot of these cancers
are 5 10 15 20 times lower in other
parts of the world because they're not
eating meat and dairy three times a day
they're not eating all this processed
sugar tons of salt tons of oils all
these refined foods and guess what
they're not getting all of it rich
people diseases that we get in rich
nations even though some people watching
this may say well I don't feel very rich
right if you live in America you're in
the you're in the top 1% richest people
in the world Yeah right
saying that includes if you live in
Canada the UK Australia New Zealand so
we eat a rich man's diet and we have
rich man's disease cancer heart disease
diabetes these are rich people diseases
what if someone says well you're an
anomaly I mean you're somebody who's
special now you were you were saved this
way you know the doctor told you you had
so much time to live and you continue on
from there so he told you that that you
only had what six years at most to live
and you
and they said I had a 60% chance these
percent chance five years five years I'm
making it to the five year mark that
didn't mean I was that doesn't mean I
would be cancer-free at five years just
means statistically as a cancer patient
the odds were 60% of cancer patients are
alive
five years after their diagnosis that's
all it means it doesn't mean they're
healthy doesn't mean they don't have
cancer just means their hearts beating
right and they're alive
they could be on their deathbed so that
statistic is virtually worthless
you're right though some people do think
oh I'm just lucky oh it's just an
anomaly or whatever and I've interviewed
and plus I've spoken to hundreds of
people that have eel cancer but I've
interviewed over 50 people on Chris beat
cancer calm my site that have healed
with nutrition and many therapies how
many were 50 now yeah I've just been
doing it my spare time you know over the
years and I've got the most incredible
healing stories and interviews on my
site and these are people who have had
even more severe cancers than me like
Stage four pancreatic cancer healed
without surgery right leukemia
breast cancer lung cancer colon cancer I
mean melanoma thyroid cancer you name it
brain cancer I interviewed a guy
yesterday haven't even posted it yet
healed his brain cancer after surgery
and radiation failed and healed it with
a macrobiotic diet
it's a plant-based diet so in in six
months his tumor was gone just from
nutrition just from a diet change you
know it's a radical diet change yeah but
that's how powerful nutrition is when
you give the body the right stuff it can
really incredible amazing things can
happen in your body and I'm not even
selling anything right not selling some
lotion or potion or pill right just
telling people like you have the power
to change and you'll be amazed at what
happens when you do make these dramatic
changes to your diet have you seen this
doctor since oh no no that you I found
it but I mean have you I mean just
purposely to go back and share your work
now because you're out there how the
here to do that and and these doctors
don't care either you see I know lots of
cancer patients and it's always the same
story when they go back to the doctor
and show the look on well the tumors
gone and they do the tests and doctor
says yeah Wow yeah that's fantastic
next yeah they don't care they do not
care and the ones that do care they're
powerless anyway they can't say wow
let's take what you did and give it and
try it with some other patients that
never happens well as doctors are
handcuffed by the medical industry to
only prescribe surgery chemo and
radiation so they don't have any
flexibility I mean another approved drug
therapies they have no flexibility no
medical freedom to treat a patient in
the manner in which that patient wants
to be treated and that's a real tragedy
and you know people like me hope to see
that change in our lifetime where
patients have medical freedom or that
you can go to the doctor and say hey I
want to be treated with this therapy and
the doctor says okay we can do that we
can work with you what are some of the
most important things that cancer
patients need to know that you advise
now through your experiences yeah
absolutely I mean the main thing that
cancer patient needs to understand is
that for for most patients is that you
have time don't rush into anything that
you don't feel good about and you have
options there's a whole world of
information on healing the body with
nutrition and natural therapies natural
non-toxic methods right that will not
make you worse they will only support
health and healing in your body and but
you do need to take full control of your
life and you need to be willing to
change everything
this is what's so important about cancer
it's a wake-up call
it's a divine tap on the shoulder and
the message is hey the way you're living
is killing you you're the only
appropriate response to that is okay
maybe I do need to change my life maybe
I need to take a hard look in the mirror
at who I am like who I've become
how am i what am i eating where am i
spending my time am i doing am i smoking
am i drinking am i staying up all night
am i you know engaged in just unhealthy
destructive living and behavior and
thoughts do I live in a toxic part of
town to our work in a toxic environment
right am i harboring a lot of bitterness
and unforgiveness and resentment and
negativity and jealousy and envy like am
I just a ball of negative emotions and
unhappiness because if the answers to
those questions are yes yes yes yes that
sounds like me then you have a lot of
work to do and the good news is you have
this huge opportunity to change
completely change who you are and how
you are right the way you live the way
you eat through your relationships
everything and so you know what I
encourage cancer patients to do it was
like I said take a hard look at their
life and then take massive action
changing everything that they know or
think might be contributing to their
sickness to their disease to their
unhappiness we know that stress is a
major promoter of cancer because stress
suppresses your immune system hey you
know most cancer patients have tons of
start stress in their life before they
get cancer then they get this diagnosis
which is a stress bomb but now their
stress is even worse than before right
and a lot of them get very depressed
right when you're depressed your immune
system just just like almost shuts down
when you're struggling with depression
anxiety and fear and so it becomes a
vicious cycle of you know stress anxiety
and fear that keeps you in a chronic
state of immunosuppression I mean cancer
patients oh it's not uncommon for them
to suffer from PTSD just from the
diagnosis right post-traumatic stress
disorder from the traumatic
life-changing event that was the cancer
diagnosis so what I'm sure what I try to
do is encourage people and to say hey
it's okay like this is not the end of
the world this
the beginning of a new chapter in your
life this is an opportunity for you to
change and you need to believe that bad
things turn into good thing
things like bad things in life always
produce good things down the road and
don't get hung up in the bad that's
happening right now you look forward to
the good that it can produce and believe
that you can get well and then take
massive action to change your life and
to promote health and healing in your
body and start reading and researching
at me go to Kris beat cancer com go to
my website it's there are hundreds of
articles and interviews with about
healing with nutrition tons of
interviews with people that have healed
all types of cancers it's all free Itzik
it's all free for you right if you want
to read and learn and be inspired and
encouraged and
learn exactly what people people have
done to heal it's right there for you so
you're not created that site to be what
didn't exist yeah for me I was sick in
2004 you know diagnosed in December 2003
and going through this process and the
internet was not helpful to me at that
time I only had a handful of books and
that was it didn't have any support
groups didn't there was no youtube
there's no Facebook none of that wasn't
there and so I was very much alone hey
is your cancer pretty much is it is it
gone now yeah my cancer has been gone
it's totally yeah it's been 12 years how
you feeling now compared to how you were
living before it's there's no comparison
man I'm in the best shape of my life I'm
healthy I'm strong I've got two
beautiful little girls that wouldn't be
here if I'm chemotherapy uh-huh I
probably wouldn't either
and a beautiful wife and and this
incredible you know opportunity and
really blessing to be able to share my
story around the world and travel and
speak and I mean man my life is awesome
it's so good I'm just so blessed
what are you doing one thing yes what if
someone says look man well these how do
you know because we're trained to
believe that doctors know best so now
you have Chris here on the one hand
telling us one thing but you have my
doctor he's that's what he went to
school for that's what he's educated for
that's why we go to see
the doctor because the doctor knows best
and he's telling me the doctors nose
knows best on what he's taught mm-hmm
they know best on what they're taught
they're taught on how to prescribe drugs
how to perform surgery had it been a
minister radiation therapy they're
experts in that stuff but if you ask
your doctor and listen I've got the best
resource for any cancer patient on my
site it's called 20 questions for your
oncologist if you think your doctor
knows best ask him these questions and
you'll find out how much he really knows
and doesn't know you know so I'll give
us a couple of those what were a couple
a couple of them and they can see the
rest on your site give her a give us a
look the first question ever here's the
problem most cancer patients don't know
that right the right questions to ask
okay so they get this diagnosis they're
totally afraid it's like deer in the
headlights right they're just shaking
with fear and anxiety they go to the
doctor and the questions they ask are am
I gonna lose my hair uh-huh am I gonna
feel bad you know can I can I work or do
I need to take off for work those are
the questions they ask right what they
need to be asking is how effective is
this treatment I mean it does the
treatment you recommend for me cure
cancer yes or no will this treatment
cure my cancer that's question number
one like and most patients don't even
ask it and they do they're surprised to
hear the doctors say well no you know
this is not a we don't know if it'll
cure it probably you know probably well
I mean they're just gonna kind of bumble
around because the answer is no for most
cancers chemo doesn't cure it right they
know it can shrink a tumor right and
everybody gets excited because they got
some chemo and their tumor shrunk a
little bit but it's gonna start growing
right away as soon as the chemo is over
and it's gonna start going more
aggressively mm-hmm another question
that patients have to ask is is this
curative or palliative
see carrot if treatment means the doctor
actually believes there's a chance slim
chance that there's a chance that the
chemo treatments that you know surgery
chemo and radiation together or whatever
they're the standard of care is the
protocol there
they're recommending that there's a
chance that it could cure the patient
right that mean that's cure house it
means no we know there's no cure for
what you have because maybe you're Stage
four or maybe you're just you have
pancreatic cancer which they've never
cured and so we're just giving you chemo
because we think it'll slow it down we
think it will extend your quality of
life you know your your yeah I'm sorry
improves your quality of life we think
it'll extend your life right but who
wants to live longer and suffer right
it's it's about stick extending your
health span not your lifespan yeah so
those are two really important questions
but there's a lot more in this guy it's
free it's free guide they just go to my
site it's right there yeah it's in the
sidebar just download it okay and take
it to your doctor and go through and the
guide is a one-hour audio where I walk
through all the questions with you and
that you there's a transcript and then
list of questions I mean it's very
comprehensive and and the the messages I
get from patients are just amazing the
feedback that they give me like I use
these questions I could not believe what
my doctor said like I'm never going back
mm-hmm right because when you ask the
right questions you get to the truth
right well that's what attorneys do
right their experts in asking the right
questions that will lead them to the
truth about you know a matter and same
way you have to be an investigative
journalist in your own care and ask
these questions and that way you know
you're gonna get some answers that can
make you think twice about moving
forward therapy or maybe maybe the
answers you get will reinforce your
confidence in the therapy that's great
that's great but don't go and do
something and agree to something blindly
but you don't understand it all and put
all of your faith it hope open trust in
a guy or woman who won't even know your
name if they saw you in the grocery
store tomorrow like why would you do
that yeah and we know that chemotherapy
is highly toxic we know that we know
that it causes cancer to become
more aggressive we know it can cause
secondary cancers new unrelated cancers
in the body we know it causes massive
damage head to toe damage in the body
brain damaged lung damage liver damage
heart damage immune system destruction
digestive system damaged peripheral
neuropathy that's where you lose the
feeling nerve damage in your fingers and
toes and you have you can lose the
feeling in your fingers you know
permanently in some cases chemo this
came out in the news this year there's a
lawsuit pending right now because I
can't remember the name which chemo drug
it was but there's a chemo drug that is
it's just since come out they caused
permanent hair loss and and believe it
was related to breast cancer or ovarian
cancer but a certain percentage of
patients women that were given this drug
lost their hair and it never grew back
and the drug company knew that it was a
side effect and it was not disclosed to
the patients
yeah I mean ya know so and by the way I
mean permanent hair loss is in the scope
of damage that chemo does to your body
is actually pretty low compared to it
destroying your immune system and making
your cancer more aggressive so anyway I
mean I can rant on this for four days
but the overall message here again is
that if you're a patient if you have
cancer or if you're trying to care for
someone keeping someone with cancer do
not agree to anything you don't
understand do not move forward in a
therapy that doesn't make sense to you
that your instincts are telling you no
doesn't matter who's telling you you
need to do it your doctor your family
your best friend or whatever if your
heart and soul and your guts are telling
you don't do this listen to them right
take time step back start reading and
researching right start going to youtube
and googling and and and learning from
all these amazing people in the world
that have come forward and said hey I
had cancer I changed my life my body
healed and Here I am five 10 15 20 years
later there's an interview on my site
with Carl helvey he's the longest living
lung cancer survivor he was diagnosed in
the 70
refused conventional treatment used
alternative methods and diet healed he's
still alive the longest-living lung
cancer survivor just happens to be the
guy who refused conventional therapy how
great is that yeah Wow and so you know
when a patient or when you start to see
these stories and hear from these people
these are real people like regular
people they're not all just trying to
sell a book or a course or whatever
they're just regular people like you and
me you know they just want to share
their story because they're so excited
that they got well and they know it'll
encourage more people and so that's the
point right the point of what I do is to
give people real hope and encouragement
and information that they can that will
empower them to take control their life
make radical changes take massive action
and repair regenerate and detoxify right
and ultimately heal that's the goal a
couple more questions before we come to
an end tell us you talked about also
this break cancer scam can you tell us a
little bit of a little bit about this
what what is this about coming no you
would think that you know so much money
has been donated so many you have so
many causes that are out there and you
know to eradicate cancer but it doesn't
seem like it's it's slowing down it's
growing so are these causes out there
are they helping really the one
statistic that is the most I'm so glad
you asked this question thank you the
most powerful statistic that the world
needs to know is that the death rate for
cancer okay that's the ultimate measure
of whether or not we're making perfect
progress that's right
the death rate the overall death rate
for all cancers has only improved by
five percent since nineteen fifty five
percent improvement since 1950 so if
that doesn't tell you that the cancer
industry is failing and that the
billions and billions hundreds of
billions of dollars
raised and spent on cancer research have
been largely a waste well then your
analytical mind is broken right so the
cancer death rate has only improved 5%
50 years for all cancers averaged out so
that means a lot of them no improvement
right
a few have childhood leukemia the
survival rate tender survival is over
90% testicular tender survival is again
about 90% and then lymphomas but our
main cancer killers breast colon and
lung there's been almost no improvement
in the death rate same with liver cancer
stomach cancer look brain cancer
pancreatic cancer so there's a huge long
list of solid tumor cancers known as
epithelial cancers that have made almost
zero progress in an improvement in the
death rate so you can't you can't buy
into and listen to all this hype about
oh there's more cancer survivors than
ever before
alright because the reason there's more
survivors is because we have a huge
industry of that is over diagnosing
people and when you over diagnose cancer
when you call things that aren't cancer
cancer then you create thousands and
thousands of new survivors that improve
your statistics but the true measure is
the death rate and anyone can research
this freely on Google you know know the
overall cancer death rate is only
improved 5% since 1950 Google and last
but not the least tell us your daily
regimen your routine what do you eat -
how much do you exercise you eat three
four times a day usually you know in the
culture if somebody's active they say
okay you should eat small meals five six
times a day that's kind of the norm but
how about you what how much are you
eating a day and how much do you reckon
how much exercise do you do alright next
resides with fundamentals of health so
you need exercise every day and I'm
moving my body every day exercise in
some way what you can is just walking
even just happening yeah Rocky
thirty minutes a day is awesome like do
that it's great you don't need weight to
that right just walk oh just moving your
body circulates your blood in your lymph
system and if you're you know if you get
a little bit more intense and break a
sweat you're improving your
detoxification you're getting fresh air
and sunshine walking is amazing so
getting out there whether it's you know
walking biking running karate yoga
CrossFit whatever it's all good like
movement is life and you need to
exercise every day as far as the diet
goes the most protective diet against
cancer the best type to protect against
it and to help heal it is a plant-based
diet plant-based diet fruits and
vegetables like crazy don't be afraid of
fruit or the sugar and freak it's
wonderful it's good for you it will help
you get well alright so unaggressive and
there's a lot of different variations of
the plant-based diet that people use to
get well I did like a raw vegan diet you
know two tons of raw vegetables and
fruit some people do the macrobiotic
diet which is more Brown focused on just
brown rice and some cooked vegetables
and sea vegetables and some fruit like
this guy mentioned them that'll be
posted on the site very soon he'll is
brain cancer that way so people do the
Gerson Therapy Gerson Therapy is also a
plant-based diet that involves more
cooked vegetables but there's a lot of
potatoes in there and root vegetables
and lots of juices throughout the day so
and then there's the nori protocol and
that's an all fruit diet to heal cancer
I know multiple people that have fueled
cancer with an all fruit diet but they
all have this in common plant-based
diets that you cut out the meat the
dairy the oils the sugar you know
processed sugar salt all the processed
food it's all the junk of course you
have to stop drinking and smoking and
you know taking drugs prescription or
illegal if you're taking prescription
drugs you need to consult with your
doctor you know I don't want you to test
stop taking the drug and your heart
stopped tomorrow but prescription drugs
all have side effects in the body that
can suppress your immune system the
amount on your liver cause you know
there's hundreds of effects right that
prescription drugs can cause in the body
and if you're sick and have it be a
problem
you're taking may be causing it right
maybe they caused new problems so people
take a prescription drug and they have
taken another drug for the side effect
of that drug so it's sound effects for
the side effects for the side effects
right and it's just this like you know
I've met people who take ten
well prescription drug is crazy it is
crazy
so I even forgot what your original
question was because I'm just ranting
yeah well I was always asking about kind
of getting to know your your daily
routine like yeah thanks plant-based
diet absolutely what I did was the first
90 days it was 100% raw it's all raw
fruits and vegetables and the details
are on my side
and then from there we dialed it back to
80% raw 20% cooked and because my
metabolism was really high I needed more
cooked food just for the calories so
brown rice and sweet potatoes and quinoa
are just wonderful cooked foods for the
body
oatmeal is wonderful so the great thing
about it is there's no perfect diet and
in a lot of different ways to get rel
but they're all centered around the diet
that's rich in from the earth such a
very simple whole foods lots of fruits
and vegetables diet again there's lots
of details on my site that people can
dig in but that's right now yeah so
twelve years later right we're gonna
have a breakfast I don't meal yeah with
flax and hemp and chia seeds and almonds
and I usually have like some blackstrap
molasses in there because it's a great
source of iron and potassium magnesium
and antioxidants and up with fresh
berries blueberries or raspberries in it
I mean just how about you how about your
cancer cell in mmm how about your
special cancer salad giant
cancer-fighting salad which I ate twice
a day for about two years is loaded with
the most potent anti-cancer vegetables
broccoli cauliflower kale onions
mushrooms to say onions yes and then
topped with garlic oregano cayenne
pepper a little bit of olive oil apple
cider vinegar sauerkraut
this is delicious delicious salad that
has the most potent anti-cancer
vegetable wasn't it all all of them
that's living food its limits living
food you're putting on your body's going
living food and my goal was really
simple it was to overdose on nutrition I
apologize if you hear like construction
in the background there's the workers in
my house doing some stuff downstairs but
yeah it was just to overdose on
nutrition I figured look anything's
better than chemo so I mean I'm going to
do anything as long as it doesn't hurt
me and that's at crispy cancer calm
Chris beats cancer calm and do you also
recommend there's a a documentary called
the truth about cancer a global quest
anything else like this that you
recommend people watch about cancer is a
docu-series like nine part docu-series
all about the cancer industry and and
people that have healed I'm featured in
it it's fantastic yeah absolutely thank
you very much Chris hopefully we can
have you back we'll get some response
from this program so people have some
more questions we can bring you on again
god willing we can have another nice
discussion I really thank you for your
time thank you this is great I want to
thank you guys I told you to enjoy this
week's episode these are things that we
as a community we need to start talking
more about if your events consists of
cookie cake and ice cream and pops and
sugary foods this is a sign right now
that you got to stop you got to
eliminate those toxic foods are toxic
foods and replace them with what your
children have a right to which you have
a right to it's a god-given right it's
right under your nose it's the real food
that's been put in the earth that the
Creator has blessed all of us with you
got to buy that you got to incorporate
that into your lifestyle and eliminate
all of these toxic foods it's something
that we need to talk about because our
kids are being affected you're being
affected your families being effective
it doesn't make sense that kids this is
the first generation they're not
expected to outlive their parents heart
disease and kids cancer in kids diabetes
they're obese a weight overweight so
either working towards good health or
you're doing the opposite
so now I'm talking about it I want the
community leaders to talk about it I
want them to take the matter seriously
get informed there's a system and if
that system is something that we've been
used to you go see the man in the white
coat he knows best but what if that
system is broke there's the deficiency
there and we got to find an alternative
take the good from that system but know
that it's limited in this area if your
doctor doesn't study nutrition this is a
known fact he doesn't know he doesn't
know to educate you on that he has to be
humbled to that aspect and he has to
grow from that otherwise that's
arrogance thinking that I know best no
the only one that knows all is the one
who created us who's the all-knowing
we're human beings we're fallible were
weak and we're learning we're on a way
to learning and exploring each and every
day but this is one of the things that
if you dig a little bit if you study a
little bit it's something so profound
it's simple to understand that the food
we're eating is either living food
that's helping us to live better or it's
fake food toxic food that's destroying
us now this is a living testimony to
that our guest of this week and there's
so many people out there they don't see
the food disease correlation so I
encourage you to look more into this
what do I get out of it I get out of it
that tomorrow you you meet me and you
say thank you for that great advice I'm
living healthier I'm able to play more
with my kids I'm I'm ecstatic I'm elated
because now my life my life is more
fruitful it's more benefit I have more
energy I'm alive and well and I'm
enjoying the blessing that the creator's
bless me with the vehicle that's going
to get me through life it's fully
functioning and it's running smoothly
thank God so make sure you take the
matter serious start taking your health
not for granted but treating it like the
blessing that is it is it's a priceless
blood blessing so make sure you're
caring for that blessing of health so we
gave you some some simple yet profound
advice with my friend Chris here
on the Dean show and look forward to
having more talks like this but I want
to see more people talking about it
taking the matter seriously especially
the community leaders who are out there
to get informed on this and to advise in
to caution people and to give that good
advice that has directly to do with good
help and preserving the blessing that
the crater God Almighty has given us of
health thank you guys very much
subscribe if you haven't already we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you